when I was a kid I was super duper shy
and I wouldn't talk to anyone and one
but i was i was very i like in loved
playing by myself and I was really
imaginative and creative and my parents
had this idea that if I did like a
theater class after school I would
somehow open up and they were right so I
started taking theatre classes when I
was about e47 and the minute I was put
on stage I started I just lit up and I
started being comfortable I think I
think you'll hear a lot of actors say
that they they were very shy and for me
I felt having grown up in New York and
being Palestinian Lebanese and having
grown up in a pretty homogeneous world
with gone to private school and not
understanding why I was I look different
and my parents book of funny language I
think I found refuge in theater because
I could be a million different things
and it was okay
I think the way it evolved was really
organic and it was came out of a journal
entry I had written so what had happened
was I had been acting professionally
from the time I graduated from college
in the late 90s until about until let's
say 2001 in 2001 actually before
September 11 a group of Arab American
artists myself included got together
because we'd all sort of met each other
but didn't really know we had none of us
had really explored our identity and we
thought it might be interesting to me
get together and talk about working on a
project about Arab American immigrants
in this country so we did and we started
working on it and then 911 happens from
in the middle of the process so we
ultimately did the play in the summer of
two thousand two but to do the
production we formed a company so out of
this company grew many things and one of
them was some education workshops that
we did with kids and I had met an
Israeli filmmaker named dan I Ilan who
is the daughter of a mo salon who is
just passed away he was a an Israeli
journalist and intellectual and she and
I long story short we're working on a
project to do in a private high school
that we both knew a student who we both
knew a student who went there and so we
each wanted to tell a part of our about
she wanted to tell about growing up in
israel and i wanted to tell about being
palestinian so we decided to each write
a piece to perform 15 minutes for these
kids a personal piece and there was
another member of my theater company who
helped us with it and did her own piece
um and I didn't know what to write so I
showed them a journal entry that I'd
written when my father passed away I was
listening to my ipod and I heard a song
that reminded me of this trip I took
when I was 18 and I just wrote this
stream of consciousness fifth in that
turned into a 15 minute performance and
then a few years later I had the
opportunity to perform it again
for Israeli and Palestinian or Israeli
an Arab playwrights and then I had a
working relationship with New York
Theatre Workshop and they invited me to
develop the piece further and I kind of
had no idea what it was going to be I I
had dabbled and stand up a little bit
and I'd been an actress for a really
long time but I didn't understand how
this sort of a monologue that was just
about my weird family would end up being
an entire play but um I took the
challenge and I am ended up working with
a drama tarragon director who really
helped me make it into a play and so it
never really occurred to me to have
other actors in it it just it and it's
also still to this day it doesn't
totally feel like a play it's a piece
that I've done where I get to show off
all my different characterizations and
abilities but it's it's purely my my
story so it's it's funny because I had
dabbled and stand up but I I didn't get
how to write a joke yeah I just could
just stand on stage and babble so this
was the perfect way for me to put all
that in and still be an actress
it's lonely um you know you find that a
lot of us who do theatre the reason we
do it is because it's all about
interaction with other people on stage
and with the audience it's a very
visceral thing whereas when you're
shooting a film you shoot scenes out of
sequence and sometimes there's no one
else there you know if you're working
with some big movie star they didn't
they're not necessarily going to be
sitting across from you you may just be
talking to a camera so so a lot of the
love of theater is because of the human
and personal interaction but what I
found was um although it's lonely it's
incredibly I mean once you once you
realize that you're on stage and I mean
first it's horrifying you realize oh my
god if I mess up there's no one here to
save me but then you also realize
everyone's listening to me which without
sanding like a total egomaniac that's
not what I mean it just it's lovely
because it really gives the story an
opportunity to be heard there's nothing
else that people can focus on or listen
to and then the connection with the
audience becomes a little more intense
which is lovely because in both of these
situations and it's not always the case
but in general I was talking to the
audience so of course that brings up a
whole nother level of difficulties
because you're not you you know in
theatre you tend to have a what's called
the fourth wall but um it's kind of nice
too because you're really talking to
people and um so I find that it you know
it can get lonely and tiring to go to
rehearsal for eight hours a day and it's
all you all the time is tiring and it it
really brings up a lot of insecurities
um because you're the only one getting
notes and you're also for this
experience I was also the writer so it's
just a lot um but it's also a challenge
and it's a total thrill and once you've
done it you're like whoa I can do
anything you're not sort of the fear of
being on stage if you ever had they're
like I'm not really i don't get stage
fright but i do get nervous like most
people so the idea that like I've done
this now twice for an hour and a half
both times I mean both productions and
gotten through full run at you just sort
of feel like I can do anything now